hey it's me again making another big ego
and so this time I'm gonna talk about
five reasons why I love the Jenners
brothers
that's Kelsea Ballerini in 2008 yeah
over ten years ago the first one is
their passion to music which I made
another video that talked about how we
kind of share that because I love to
sing and I love to write songs and they
do too and so I think that would be an
awesome thing to meet someone who has
that same passion but is living their
dream out and I think that we really
couldn't talk to them about she shared
that video on Instagram along with this
pic finally meeting Kevin Joe and Nick
Jonas for caption quote only took 12
years to win the Joe bro meet-and-greet
swipe for my 2008 contest entry from
deep in the archives okay goodbye safe
to say Kelsey not only met the Joe Broz
but had an epic time at their Nashville
Show
[Music]
yeah she posted tons of videos to her
story and not only that but she also
joined bebe Rexha on stage she's opening
for the Joe Broz
[Music]
talk about a glow up for Kelsey and
overall just a full-circle moment Keith
Urban also showed up posing for this pic
with Joe backstage he was with Joe Broz
on the night they kicked off their
happiness begins tour it's an incredible
feeling and and you know this this tour
in a lot of ways was kind of the perfect
storm everything in between sucker and
cool the other songs and the record
coming out I think all of it was kind of
pointing towards this moment to be back
on stage together see our fans we
haven't seen in six seven years and
there's a magic to it that we can't
explain we're just we're feel that we're
kicking this thing off what is different
this time - back then there's quite a
bit I'd say our hair is a little shorter
yeah a little bit yeah yeah yeah the
hair was yeah the pants are a little bit
looser I don't know they're still pretty
skinny their skinny jeans still button
our voices maybe are a little bit
different deeper voices but the songs
are still there our excitement on
getting this stage every night and
performing with these fans we're kind of
still blown away
[Music]